my name is george moats and i know a lot
about hamburgers now sam
yeah that's obnoxious
uh was i saying
i've traveled all over the world and
i've seen the way the american hamburger
has been translated
it's fascinating today i present to you
the longosh burger this burger is a
deep-fried burger that has roots in
eastern europe
it's invented by some friends of mine in
brooklyn with a restaurant called corzo
it's a burger that's wrapped up in
hungarian dough
called langosh this burger is cooked
separately
and then wrapped in dough and plunged in
hot oil
yeah that's right unquestionably we're
about to go
on a science adventure right now because
look at how much [ __ ] is going
it's got i've got a flat top i've got a
deep frying
setup and i have i'm gonna have flour
and dough it's gonna be crazy so
for the record i've never done this
before i made dough
we know how to make burgers i know the
ingredients and we are going to try this
for the first time
on camera anything could happen
right
[Laughter]
let's make a burger let's make a
deep-fried burger what are you doing
what are you doing
what are you doing yeah you go
yeah there you go nice work food
wrapped in dough and cooked somehow it's
nothing new and you're ready for this
one
there's a good chance that it pre-dates
the hamburger
but i want you to think about this now
let's take a little trip around the
world
and think about all of those dough
wrapped foods that exist today
okay you've got empanada of argentina
hello
you've got the dumpling of asia you have
the pierogi of eastern europe
you have the pastel the pride of brazil
you have the cornish pasty
from cornwall england so now that you
know the relatives to this hamburger
let's get cooking
this is gonna be a mess we're gonna make
a mess
keep oil at about 350 375 degrees
somewhere there
flat top should be somewhere around
4 20.
i'm making bacon
[Music]
if you cook bacon in a big strip it's
you know
it's gonna be sticking out the end of
this thing or you break it in half i
don't wanna break my bacon
i'm gonna cook it in a circle just like
that see that look at that let's roll
some dough out
a little bit of flour flour in my hands
my dough i made this dough here's the
thing i called my friends otto and maria
zizak
for the recipe for their longoshi dough
because it's so
tasty and so authentic and they said
yeah sure we'll give it to you and
they sent me an email with the
ingredients but not the recipe
and they said we do it by hand and by
eye figure it out
so i'm obviously on my own here it's
very similar to a pizza dough
it's pretty stretchy it should be kind
of stretchy i can't quite get it to
stretch out
the way i want but it will
oh [ __ ] i've already got a hole in it oh
no that's not gonna be good
maybe no i don't know this is gonna be
interesting
baking is not my thing get the yeast
raise the dough proof the dough whatever
it's called i don't know i'm not a baker
i have no idea
it's looking like about that big is big
enough i think i don't know
we're gonna find out i have a pre-formed
patty from a ring look at that look how
perfect that is here we go burger my
burger journey has led me around the
united states but it's also led me
around the world
when i travel i pick up things mementos
from all over the place
you want to see some of my things
check out my collection of curiosities
from around the world including this
thing on my head which is
emboya it's a gauchos bonya for
argentina
had to wave that one in right of course
silly this is black sand from the black
sand beach in iceland
sorry iceland i stole your sand this is
ridiculous this is a
toy oh [ __ ] it's broken
but this is from a vending machine in
tokyo
it's a porta potty it's a little you
know public toilet
but it's complete with a little toilet
inside there i'm not sure
why they made those but i had to buy it
oh these are toothpicks these are the
best toothpicks in the world
from brazil check this out friends of
mine in
copenhagen put me on the cover of their
magazine
burgers look at that oh that's beautiful
it's a thick burger so a few minutes you
also don't want to overcook this it's
going to be in the deep fryer for
a minute evan taller first down
the bacon the pickles and then the
mustard
i'm probably doing this all wrong i'm
sure the zizzaks are laughing at me
right now
i think this is done let me just ready
to go this is going here like this
it's like an upside down burger you like
that look at that
perfect here's the hard part i'm not
sure what i have to do here i think i
have to wet my hands to get it to stick
together
but i'm gonna try to stretch it our eye
did it work okay look at that hey
is it working i don't know how do they
do this
i pinch i pull and separate
i pinch i strain you ready people i
don't know what's gonna happen here this
could be a complete disaster
but look at that thing it's pretty cool
huh oh it's definitely got a hole in it
already
oh well i'm gonna gently lower this in
here
ready go
get it check oh so much for gentle oh
god
[Music]
no okay just happened i'm not sure okay
oh okay holy [ __ ] this might actually
work
now you imagine what's going on inside
this thing it's
hot oil which means the insides are
still cooking inside which means that
the cheese hopefully is melting
nicely i'm going to try to turn this
over gently
didn't work hang on one more did i make
a mess over there oh jesus christ
hang on hang on all right there we go
hey
look at that you're supposed to fry
longosh
dough until it's golden brown it's
looking pretty golden i think
i don't know i think we're done here
look at that
and everybody out there watching is
thinking what's gonna happen when he
puts this in his mouth
i tell you right now i'm sure you are
the deep-fried longosh
burger from corso that's kind of hard
there you go ah that's really hot
actually
holy [ __ ]
oh my god we did it
ah look at that
oh my goodness they [ __ ] did it
the cheese is melted that is amazing
that looks really good actually
it's still too hot to handle jesus
christ it's hot
huh
[Music]
oh my god
holy [ __ ] that's it
oh good
huh no
[ __ ] that's delicious that's
ridiculously good
whoa you think
i got a hmm backstage there oh my god
oh my god it's good right i've made a
mess
in the name of science in the name of
hamburgers but it actually worked
[Music]
the deep fried langos burger
because why not
see you next time
hola amigos
hey my name is george moats don't forget
to like and subscribe to first we feast
and get more episodes of burger scholar
right here
where